Hi, this is Sal Khan,
founder of the Khan Academy,
and I'm just here to
remind everyone watching
that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization,
which means no one owns Khan Academy,
we are a public charity,
and we are dependent on donations.
And donations from folks like you
are what allow us to create the content
and the interactive software
that you and folks like you use.
So I encourage you to
think of making a donation,
even a few dollars from
everyone watching this video
would cover Khan Academy's
costs for the coming year.
We're a small team here at Khan Academy,
under 100 folks, and
we're literally reaching
tens of millions of people every month.
So the social return on an
investment here is quite high.
So, once again, really
encourage you to consider
donating even a few dollars.
Thank you.